as the omicron variant spreads across
the country many parents are once again
wondering about the potential impact of
the pandemic in their kids mental health
and emotional health in the past couple
of years the rate of psychological
distress in young people has increased
dramatically 25 percent experienced
depressive symptoms and 20 percent
experience anxiety symptoms negative
emotions like impulsive behavior and
irritability also increased in early
2021 emergency visits for suspected
suicide attempts were up 4 percent among
adolescent boys and 51 percent for girls
we're joined now by jamie howard senior
clinical psychologist at the child mind
institute good morning jamie
good morning good morning how are you
doing now the surgeon general said the
pandemic has exacerbated the
unprecedented stresses facing young
people today what have you seen the past
couple of years in your work
my colleagues and i have never been
busier than we have been over the past
couple years certainly there is a huge
demand for treatment for kids young
adults adolescents adults too
um so we're all doing the best we can
and you've probably heard that there's
somewhat of a wait for a lot of families
to get in to see mental health care
providers and so we're all doing
everything we can to make sure we can
meet this need
dr howard every parent out there has
after bedtime had a moment where they
think to themselves reflecting on their
child's behavior is it normal are these
struggles part of development or is it
not is it a sign i need to worry about
where is that line what advice can you
give parents
so we want to look at something called
functional impairment so when we think
about kids their jobs that's what that's
how they function so their jobs are to
go to school and do the best they can
whatever that means for them to make and
keep friends to engage in activities
that they enjoy and to love their
families so when we look at how kids are
functioning we want to keep in mind
these four main areas so are they
engaged in what they're learning are
they seeing friends do they seem
connected to you
uh these are the things that can guide
us when we're not so sure
so how do you know dr howard if there's
a problem because i think seven to eight
times out of ten if you say to your
child how are you doing they'll say fine
right everything's fine or they don't
want to talk to you about it whatsoever
so how do you break through to start a
conversation and what should you be
looking out for you've touched on it
briefly
yeah so i think what we want to do is is
create
opportunities to discuss this keep an
open line of communication a lot of
times we don't have great vocabulary for
talking about our emotions and our
behaviors and so the more that you can
bring the conversation up and normalize
it and not necessarily jump to
a dramatic kind of conversation kids
hate that especially teenagers so the
more that you can sort of they chill and
continue to engage them um the more
likely they will wait jamie jamie what
did you call that fake chill is that
what you called it fake chill you yeah
well you want to be chill try and fake
it till you make it even if you have to
that's okay
yeah yeah yeah jamie um i was once told
when it comes to my own mental health
treat it like mask falling from above on
a turbulent flight in other words
assist yourself before you assist your
child
so for
parents or caregivers that might be
dealing with their own mental health
issues what advice do you give them
before they go and approach their own
kids
absolutely there's so there's so much
importance there because you're modeling
taking care of yourself and you're
destigmatizing mental health care
by getting treatment yourself so if you
can sort of vocalize that and say you
know what i've been feeling really
anxious with the omicron variants now
spreading across the country something
i'm focusing on is staying in the
present moment even though we have to
tolerate uncertainty that's so much
better
than sort of getting stuck in worst case
scenarios and so the more that you can
talk about it and model what you're
doing the more that your child will feel
comfortable to open up to you
so dr howard if you've succeeded as a
parent and you've been fake chill and
your child has opened up to you and
you've realized that there there's been
a break in their pattern of behavior all
that's going right and you think there's
an issue what's the next step
who do you go to what do you google
well so you can always google our
website childminds.org but another good
person to reach out to is your
pediatrician or a school psychologist um
because these people will have
connections to care in your community um
the thing we want parents to know is
there's no harm in getting an evaluation
the worst case scenario is someone will
evaluate your child and say you know i
don't think this is quite at a clinical
threshold yet but here are some things
you can do so there's no harm in that
but there's so much good in getting an
evaluation because these disorders are
real they're common they're treatable
and they're even preventable
all right dr jamie howard we thank you
for your time and your advice this
morning thank you have a good holiday
have a good holiday happy holidays